bonjour claude bonjour heureuse de vous
retrouver dans la matinale adhère t
france alors ce rapprochement ressemble
à une bonne nouvelle son étude et l
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
évidemment traditionnellement l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite
sont des pays rivaux pour des raisons
religieuses d'abord puisque l'iran se
veut littéraire d'aidé chiite et
l'arabie saoudite des sunnites pour des
raisons politiques aussi parce que
lorsque les mollahs ont pris le pouvoir
en 79 évidemment ils n'ont pas eu de
bons rapports avec l'arabie saoudite
monarchie traditionalistes et puis il y
eut en effet les motifs comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure de rupture des
relations diplomatiques et à 6 ans avec
l'ambassade de l'arabie saoudite en iran
qui a été pris d'assaut par la
population après l'exécution d'un d'un
religieux importants en arabie saoudite
et il se trouve que en effet depuis un
an les relations très discrètement
repris sous l'égide de l'irak qui a joué
les bons offices
et qu' il ya déjà eu comme vous l'avez
des quatre réunions que ces réunions
sont passés de la responsabilité des
services secrets à la responsabilité des
mises affaires étrangères et que on
attend une cinquième réunion très
prochainement également en irak qui
devrait finalement aboutir à la au
rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques et déjà en baisse pour
mohamed benslimane a fait des
déclarations disant qu'il souhaitait que
les relations s'améliorent et mêmes qu'à
un consulat iranien puisse ouvrir à
djeddah alors l'arabie saoudite en se
rapprochant de l'iran et c'est l2 de se
désengager d'avoir un peu moins de
dépendance vis-à-vis des etats-unis et
quelle serait alors la réaction des
états unis je crois d'abord qu'elle fait
un constat réaliste c'est à dire que les
états unis veulent se désengager de la
région des conflits de la région et que
les puissances importante dans la région
cherchent à prendre en main le destin de
la région alors on voit bien que à
téhéran comme en arabie saoudite
il ya l'idée que les deux pays peuvent
jouer un rôle important dans les
conflits locaux et notamment dans le
conflit qui les oppose au yémen puisque
c'était le fait générateur de la
première réunion en irak il ya un an
c'était d'essayer de calmer les choses
puisque l'iran soutient les rebelles
houthi et que l'arabie saoudite avec
d'ailleurs des armes américaines
soutient le régime les légitimistes
il ya aussi le fait que l'arrivée de by
dane au pouvoir a changé la donne parce
que jobs soutenait systématiquement
l'arabie saoudite et dans le fond
vendait les armes toutes les armes que
l'arabie saoudite lui demander compris
les larmes létale contre les outils et
qu'abidal arrivant au pouvoir a voulu
repasser réexaminer les relations avec
l'arabie saoudite et notamment parce
qu'il était assez choqué avec benken
d'ailleurs par les conditions de la
disparition de l'assassinât de cash dit
ce journaliste saoudien qui a été donc
assassiné en fait dans un consulat dans
un consulat est un peu à istanbul et
donc ceci a fait prendre conscience aux
fûts du fait que probablement il y avait
intérêt à prendre une certaine distance
par rapport aux etats-unis tout en
restant l'alliée des états unis bien sûr
l'arabie saoudite était est un allié
important des états unis mais avec be
avec blinken et avec byden sous bénéfice
d'inventaire et qu'est ce que l'iran a
donc à gagner sur la scène
internationale avec ce rapprochement
dire on a beaucoup à gagner et on voit
bien dans les déclarations des officiels
iraniens que
probablement il pense maintenant que il
faut trouver une solution pour mettre
fin à la guerre au yémen qui est à une
guerre qui est très impopulaire au bout
du compte même si les regarde la
communauté internationale ne sont pas
fixés par part cela il ya énormément de
morts il ya des conditions humanitaires
épouvantable et ceci risquerait de se
retourner un jour contre les sponsors
des rebelles houthi c'est à dire contre
l'iran la deuxième chose c'est que
l'iran cherche véritablement à faire
lever les sanctions américaines les
sanctions économiques pour que son
économie puisse reprendre pied et que la
population ne se retourne pas contre les
dirigeants iraniens et c'est toute la
négociation de vienne et peut-être que
aussi de ce point de vue là l'iran
souhaite lâcher du lest et bleu biz
affaires étrangères iranien a dit
récemment qu'il souhaitait que l'iran
l'arabie saoudite mais aussi l'egypte et
la turquie donc les puissances moyennes
très importante dans la région prennent
en main la solution des difficultés et
des tensions qui ont lieu dans toute
cette région merci beaucoup claude pour
cet éclairage c'est l édito diplôme de
la matinale d'ayrté france ce matin
[Musique]